das hier ist die weltweit erste KFC
Pasta m und sie schmeckt besser als sie
sollte ich habe nämlich noch ein
bisschen original KFC Panade über und
aus der mache ich einfach den Teig für
die Nudeln das heißt wir nehmen uns die
Panade und geben 200 g in eine Schüssel
und Eier rein wenn unser Teig fertig
verknetet ist decken wir ab für 20
Minuten der Teig hat eine schöne
Konsistenz jetzt teile ich mir den auf
und abgeht die wilde Fahrt rein in die
Nudelmaschine es sieht jetzt schon ein
bisschen verboten aus mit den ganzen
Gewürzen drin und so entsteht die
weltweit erste KFC Pasta die Pasta ist
fertig kümmern wir uns um die Soße wir
machen eine Alfredo Soße Butter ist
geschmolzen wir geben ein paar Zwiebeln
dazu Knoblauch jetzt gehen wir ein
bisschen Mehl dran machen eine
Mehlschwitze dann können wir auch schon
anfangen unsere Sahne drauf zugeben
jetzt gehen wir auch unsere KFC Pasta
ins Wasser und kochen Sie bis Sie
hochschwimmt unsere Pasta ist alidente
es wird Zeit sie zu unserer Soße
hinzuzufügen alter Schwede guckt euch
mal an wie cremig diese Pasta ist jetzt
nehmen wir unsere Pasta rein in die KFC
Box eine Sache fehlt noch KFC chicken
chicken klein schneiden oben drauf